now the crop of 20 22 republican
candidates just got a lot stronger
tonight as football legend herschel
walker announced that he's jumping into
the georgia gop center primary to take
on incumbent democrat rafael warnock
take a look i'm a conservative
not because someone told me to be
i'm a conservative because i believe in
smaller government
a strong military
personal responsibility and making sure
all people have the opportunity to
pursue their dreams
that's an america worth fighting for
[Music]
my name
and i'm running for the united states
senate i'm a kid from a small town in
georgia who's lived the american dream
[Music]
and hershel walker joins us hershel
great to see you um we've been friends a
long time and and by the way buckle up
you just entered the blood sport of
politics and i see the attacks already
begun
and i laugh because i know you
personally and they are not going to be
able to intimidate you even some
republicans will join in forces and you
will be staying in the race for sure why
did you decide to make this jump
we need
leaders like you you are a leader a
natural-born leader
well first of all sean let me say this
here
that i want everyone to go to uh
teamherschel.com
because you're right the left and the
right are coming after me
but if the people want a fighter to go
to washington that are ready to get down
in the swamp you're looking at him right
here because i don't care i don't i
don't want to sit on the sidelines
anymore and see this country and see
what's happening in this country because
this is not the america i grew up in and
it's not the america i want to leave for
my kids for anyone else's kids you know
i think we need to have a strong
military we cannot be uh
give our word away how in the world
could you uh leave your allies you gave
them your word how can you leave
american people you know we need leaders
that i said a long time ago to go to
washington and do what's right and
you're looking at him right here that's
why i told you right now go to
teamherscher.com and put me in
washington and i guarantee you i'm going
to fight for you
you know you say that and you know you
we we've talked a lot over the years and
we've become friends over the years and
um what i think i want
everybody to know about you is
you are guided by your own principles
you know you don't you did not get in
this race with any idea that you're
going to lose and when i spoke to you
recently you said to me sean my only my
only goal here is to serve the people of
georgia
my whole life is because of georgia you
told me that
and i have i have told you that and you
know i've said it many many times so
when people say hershey is not of
georgia i've said no i owe everything to
georgia i owe everything things to
wrightsville georgia everything to my
parents but mostly to the state of
georgia because whatever i've done the
state of georgia has gotten behind me
right now and right now it's very
pivotal that this state have a
conservative like myself to get in
washington and let the people know this
country is going down the drain unless
we stand up and to be honest sean i need
to say this you know young people out
there you know i was like you sometimes
i stayed on the sideline i didn't vote
you know i just figured this is not
going to touch me but right now i'm
telling you what's happening right now
you got to wake up wake up and say i got
to get into this game and that's what
i'm saying i'm going to get into this
game and i'm saying guys this is not the
america i grew up and this is not the
america i want to be a part of we're
we're a great country so quit trying to
divide us quit trying to separate us
because we're together this is the
reason we're the greatest country in the
world is we have people that come
together and what i want to do is bring
the people together i want to go to
washington try to you know get people
together so we can get things done for
this country get things done for the for
the people you know it is sad that
parents now can't even go to the store
and afford different things gas prices
are going off the roof things are just
getting ridiculous and you can't do it
we can't live like this you support i've
asked you lower taxes tell me where you
where you don't support it
school choice
law and order
energy independent secure borders uh
constitutionalists on the bench you
support uh free and fair trade peace
through strength uh you believe in
liberty freedom capitalism and our
constitution
all true
uh that's all true that's all true you
know when you start talking about
education why is there not one education
or education for everyone instead of
having two or three education why don't
you have one where everyone go to get a
good education and i think that's what's
so important that's what we got to have
people to fight for for responsibility
right now that's what i want to do is
bring back responsibility so i'm telling
you
go to
teamhurster.com
go to team rehearsal dot com and give
five ten dollars whatever you can keep
whatever you can give to put me in
washington and i guarantee you i'm gonna
fight for you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else